what exactly is inside of that bulging
pimple it's probably even worse than you
think that white pus is packed with a
cocktail mix of bacteria dead skin cells
white blood cells and an oily waxy
material called sebum under the right
conditions these four ingredients create
the perfect storm for infection here's
how inside each pore of your skin are
tiny sacs called sebaceous glands these
glands secrete an oily material called
sebum which lubricates and waterproofs
your hair but that's not the only thing
sebum is good for it's also an energy
source for a type of bacteria called
Propionibacterium acnes normally
Propionibacterium acnes lives
harmoniously in and on your skin but
sometimes it gets out of control and
that's when the trouble starts when your
sebaceous glands grow more active like
during puberty they generate a surplus
of sebum the excess sebum can clog your
pores the pore is now a food fest for
bacteria which start to multiply out of
control this triggers alarms in your
body which identifies the infestation as
a threat so your body dispatches white
blood cells to the area to fight the
abnormally large cluster of bacteria as
a result the area becomes inflamed
causing the skin at the surface to swell
and redden eventually that swelling will
come to a head literally even worse
popping the pimple opens a gateway for
additional bacteria on your fingers
which could prolong or even worsen the
already infected pore so the next time
you have the urge to pop a pimple
consider the consequences